lo que haremos en este vídeo será hacer
algún calentamiento con unas cuantas
sumas de un solo dígito y que nos
servirán para poder entonces tener
facilidad en las sumas vamos a empezar
con una fácil que tal 2 + 4 2 + 4 es
igual a 6 de hecho esas ya no las
sabemos porque son de las que poco a
poco hemos ido aprendiendo nos de
cualquier manera si ustedes necesitan
sacar la línea de números adelante
hagamos otra 9 más 3
esta la hicimos en el vídeo pasado se
acuerdan 93 es igual a 12 una más 67
está la puse en específico porque a mí
me resulta complicado aprenderme la
entonces 6 más 7 es igual a 13 86 es
igual a 14
y de la misma manera 77 es igual a 14
como es que sabemos esto tiene sentido a
este 8 le quitamos uno se vuelve 7 este
6 le sumamos uno se vuelve 7 y de
cualquier manera nos dará 14 si esto a
ustedes los confunde y ignoren lo ignora
no por el momento
hagamos otro cambiamos el color para que
esto se vea interesante 8 + 8 es igual a
16 veamos otras 5 más
6 56 es igual a 11
pueden ir contando con los dedos de la
mano o la línea de números como ustedes
se sientan más seguros en caso de que
aún no se los aprendan cambiamos el
color cuánto será 7 + 9 7 + 9 es igual a
16 de la misma manera sigamos adelante
con cuánto será veamos 9 + 99 más 9 es
igual a 18
y hagamos una más hagamos que tal 9 + 8
9 8 será una menos que la anterior
porque el 9 le quitamos 1 y es la única
diferencia que tenemos entonces 9 + 8
será 1 menos que 18 es decir 17 ya se
sienten listos para hacer sumas con dos
dígitos ya calentamos bastante vamos a
empezar con las sumas de dos dígitos
qué tal 22 más 3
vamos a trabajar igual que en el vídeo
pasado dividamos estos números por
columnas la columna de unidades y la
columna de decenas tomaremos únicamente
la de unidades para empezar y haremos 2
+ 3 es igual a 5
listo es parte de estos que ya vamos
conociendo poco a poco ahora tomaremos
la columna de las decenas donde 2 +0 es
igual a 2
por lo tanto 22 más 3 es igual a 25
hagamos una más 38 más
volvamos a hacer la separación por
columnas y tomaremos únicamente 87 será
igual a no hicimos ocho más siete cierto
vamos a escribirla aquí arriba ocho más
siete es igual
tenemos uno más en el 7 y el 7 está
igual por lo tanto este 14 sumará 1 más
14 15
87 es igual a 15 cambiamos el color para
hacerlo más claro
87 tomaremos este 15
y es de dos cifras de la misma manera el
5 que representa las unidades 5 pesos la
pondremos en las unidades y nos
llevaremos nuestra moneda de 10
arrastrándola hacia la columna de
decenas así es que ahora tenemos uno más
tres más uno es igual a cinco
vamos a colocar este 5 también hagamos
una más
más complicada 47 más 9
misma mecánica ustedes ya saben cómo
dividimos unidades y decenas
tomaremos primero las unidades y
sumaremos 79 ya la tenemos por acá
veamos 79 es igual a 16 igual tomaremos
el 6 nuestros 6 pesitos y arrastraremos
nuestra moneda de 10 pesos hacia las
decenas por lo que ahora tenemos uno más
cuatro uno más cuatro es igual a cinco
ahora 47 más 9 es igual a 56
ok es momento de irnos como los
profesionales vamos a hacer una que sea
suficientemente complicada para que vean
que ustedes ya pueden hacer sumas
importantes cuánto será 99 más 88
vamos a separar una vez más nuestras
columnas y tomaremos 98 está aquí arriba
lo ven 17
el 7 lo colocamos y arrastramos nuestra
moneda de 10 19 10 + 8 18
vamos a colocarlo aquí
este 8 lo llevaremos a nuestra columna y
este 1 lo pondremos en una nueva columna
que llamaremos de centenas eso significa
de cientos
vamos a ver la estructura de este 18
este 18 es el que viene de las unidades
correspondientes a la columna anterior y
este 1 corresponde al nuevo que estamos
arrastrando que crea una nueva columna a
la cual ya hemos llamado centenas
estamos todos claros vamos a sumar ese 1
+ 0 + 0 porque no hay nada dentro de esa
columna entonces bajará directamente
este 1 hasta colocarlo y tendremos el
total de 187 99-88 es igual a 187
yo creo que estamos listos para hacer
sumas con números larguísimos
larguísimos larguísimos tal vez de 8 o
10 de 15 cifras que se yo vamos a hacer
una muy grande para que ustedes vean que
el mecanismo es el mismo y que ya lo
conocen por lo que ya lo pueden hacer
ustedes vamos a hacer una grande tal vez
de tres no a cuatro cifras de una vez
veamos cuántos serán la suma de cuatro
mil 368 más
y este si se ve importante
ustedes saben perfectamente ya cómo
hacerlo vamos a hacerlo juntos hagamos
un poco de espacio siempre es importante
tener espacio para poder
explicarlo correctamente
ok vamos a hacer nuestras separaciones
por columnas yo las estoy poniendo en un
color mucho muy clarito para que ustedes
poco a poco lo hagan sólo de forma
mental
ya no habrá necesidad de colocarlas
tenemos unidades decenas centenas y
ahora tendremos miles
más adelante lo escribiremos
vamos a tomar nuestra primera columna
correspondiente a las unidades ocho más
dos es igual a diez tomaremos este 10 y
lo colocaremos el 0 en unidades
arrastraremos el 1
ahora haremos la suma de la siguiente
columna la siguiente columna son las
decenas y quedó de la siguiente manera 1
+ 6 + 7 es igual a 16 es igual a 777 lo
tenemos aquí arriba veamos 7 + 7 es
igual a 14
así es que utilizaremos este 14 para
poderlo colocar abajo es por eso que me
gusta tenerlos a la mano por eso la
práctica 7 + 7 es igual a 14 tomaremos
el 4 y arrastramos el 1 tenemos este 1
dentro de la siguiente columna
esta columna la llamaremos centenas con
la sede casa de centenas y sumemos ahora
tenemos uno más tres más cinco es igual
a 13 4 459 insisto pueden sacar ustedes
su línea de números un poco a poco se
los van a aprender en este caso sabemos
que es igual a 9
y este 9 es solo un dígito lo llevaremos
directo a la columna que corresponde de
las centenas y dado que solo un dígito
dejaremos vacío ya no estamos
arrastrando nada hacia la siguiente
columna esta cuarta columna es la
columna de los miles
y en este caso sumaremos
0 4
este 4 bajará directamente y es igual a
4 porque es 40 entonces tenemos que el
total de 4 mil 368 más 572 es igual a 4